troupeau des laitiers avec leur garde
manger d'un côté leurs cousines siècles
d'histoire et de nouvelle page qui
s'ouvre pour les moines de cîteaux celui
de la vente sur internet pointe d'humour
en prime
chaque année plus de cent mille fromages
sortent de l'abbaye
problème la conjoncture n'est pas
vraiment porteuse et personne n'y
échappe pas même à -2 cisterciens on
n'arrive pas à vendre
parce que il ya moins de monde qui vient
dans notre magasin les grossistes qui
viennent aliments surtout des
restaurants qui sont actuellement fermés
donc petit à petit le stock des fromages
monte monte n'augmente le risque serait
de les jeter
c'est innommable
en cette fin d'hiver les 250 vaches
donnent taplin voilà qui complique
encore un peu la donne le salut viendra
donc d'internet et la providence et bien
rendez vous on avait prévu comme
objectif une tonnes de fromage en se
disant que peut-être un jour par on ne
sait quel miracle on y arriverait en
fait on est déjà une tonne cinq ans même
pas 24 heures donc ça marche bien je
pense qu'être deux facteurs qui jouent
le premier c'est effectivement le
fromage qui est très réputé et puis
ensuite peut-être dans cette pub de
colis de les gens qui veulent se
recentrer sur des achats qui ne capte
plus de san suu kyi qui ont un acte
d'engagement plus forts tels que les
produits et puis cela marque le coup
d'essai est un coup de maître
le son du bon usage d'internet ça touche
d'autres publics un peu l'équipe plus
loin potentiellement n'importe où où ils
peuvent regarder mais aussi probablement
plus jeune plus urbain autre effet de
cette appels sur les réseaux d'humour ce
matin dans la boutique de l'abbaye
c'est une question de solidarité avec
les avec les moines comme mon ami m'a
envoyé un texto en me disant
l'idée stocks à la bévue qu'en ce moment
il travaille pas trop avec les
restaurateurs autant les aider autrement
un élan qui compte le fromage assure
plus de 60% des revenus de l'abbaye de
cîteaux et des seize religieux qui y
vivent